okay so the topic of this video is to
kind of compare and contrast solutions
that are hypotonic versus ones that are
hypertonic so let's get started okay
well first of all what is a solution
well it's a mixture where one substance
will dissolve in another and the
solution generally has two parts to it
there is the solute it's the parts that
are actually dissolved and then here's
some solutes in my picture here the
esses are symbolic of the solutes and
then there's the solvent now in a
biological solution that solvent is
typically water so here I have in my
animation here I have solutes and water
mixed together well let me ask you what
makes sense does it make sense to say
that sugar dissolved in the water or
water dissolved in the sugar I hope it
makes sense to say that the sugar
dissolved in the water because the sugar
dissolved its the solute the water
caused the sugar to dissolve so the
water is the solvent well here's a cell
and if we zoom on into this area right
here in the cell membrane we see the
phospholipid bilayer the vertical cell
membrane right there and this is our
cell membrane or a plasma membrane you
might know that it is semipermeable
meaning that certain molecules can pass
freely but others cannot well let me add
some water molecules on both sides of
the plasma membrane the cell membrane
and let me add some solute molecules to
both sides of the plasma membrane now
when we say the plasma membrane is
summer I pop up semipermeable so water
is able to pass through the cell
membrane
now if remember as Moses the movement of
water from high to low concentration so
water will generally move from the
higher concentrated area to the lower
concentrated area but water is able to
pass from one side of the cell membrane
to the other
but molecules like the solutes for a
variety of reasons are incapable of
passing through our cell membrane here
and for a variety reasons such as
sometimes solutes are too large
sometimes solutes have a charge on them
that make them unable to pass through
the cell membrane here so the plasma
membrane generally can allow water to
pass freely but not the solutes
okay so let's go ahead and talk about a
hypotonic solution now it's one with a
lower concentration of solutes and that
is contrasted to a hypertonic solution
one with a greater concentration of
solutes in my picture here I've got a
beaker filled with a fluid and an A over
exaggerated size of a cell on the inside
let's pretend the solution in the beaker
is 80% water 20% solute but the solution
in the cell is 60% water 40% solute well
where is the hypotonic solution you have
two choices which solution is hypotonic
the definition of hypotonic is one with
a lower concentration of solutes
therefore the solution in the beaker in
this example is hypotonic because the
20% solute is a lower concentration than
the 40% solute in the cell in which
solution is hypertonic by definition
hypertonic is one with a greater
concentration of solutes that would be
the solution in the cell because the 40%
solutes in the cell is greater than the
20% solute in the in the water outside
the cell
so now that I've labeled the solutions
outside of the cell as hypotonic and the
solution inside of the cell is
hypertonic I want to ask you what would
happen to a cell that is placed in a
hypotonic solution this cell right here
is placed in a hypotonic solution well
we remind ourselves the definition of
osmosis it's the movement or the
diffusion of water from a high
concentration to a low concentration
well where is the high water
concentration at if you look at the
picture you can see 80% is a higher
percentage than 60% so water would
diffuse or enter into this cell over
time over time the cell would begin to
swell and get larger and larger and
to the point where it actually could
even burst depending upon how much water
flowed into it well let's look at the
this situation right here let's change
the concentration a little bit now
pretend the solution in the beaker is
50% water 50% of solute but the solution
in the cell is still the same 60% water
40% in solute
well what solution which of these choice
a or choice B which solution would be
considered hypotonic hypotonic is one
with a lower concentration of solutes so
therefore the solution in the cell is
now considered the hypotonic solution
because the 40% is a lower percentage
than the 50% and which solution would be
considered hypertonic by definition
hypertonic is one with a greater
concentration of solutes and that's the
solution in the beaker 50% is a greater
percentage than 40% so now that i've
labeled this solution as hypertonic the
solution in the beaker is hypertonic in
this example what would happen to a cell
placed in a hypertonic solution again we
remind ourselves the definition of
osmosis the movement - the diffusion of
water from a high to low concentration
where is the higher water concentration
at look in the picture I see that 60% is
a higher percentage than 50% so
therefore water would actually diffuse
out of this cell it would it could start
to shrivel and and and lose kind of some
of its water mass as a result okay well
here is our cell again and out like we
saw before let's go ahead and zoom into
this area of the cell membrane and when
we do zoom into this area we can go
ahead and again label the cell membrane
there plasma membrane as being
my permeable and let me add 15 water
molecules inside the cell and let me add
five solute molecules inside the cell on
the outside let me go ahead and add five
water molecules and let me add five
solute molecules okay so now that I set
up this situation where do these two
labels go does the hypotonic label go on
the left or right
does the hypertonic label go on the left
or right well look at the percentages 15
waters five solutes that's a total of 20
molecules so we have 75% water solution
25% solute solution on the right hand
side we have a 50/50 solution 50% water
50 percent solute so now I can go ahead
and label the solution on the left is
hypotonic and the one on the right is
hypertonic hypotonic on the Left
hypotonic is a solution with a lower
amount a lower concentration sorry lower
concentration of solutes 25% is a lower
concentration than 50 percent now what
would happen over time remember what is
water do over time it through osmosis it
will diffuse watch the water on the Left
it will diffuse slowly over time until
there's an equilibrium of balance
well let's riad our percentages now
there's only ten water molecules on the
Left that would be 67 percent water 33
percent solute now what about the
right-hand side over time now that
diffusion and osmosis has occurred there
are now 10 water molecules on the
right-hand side that would also be a
sixty-seven percent water 33 percent
solute notice how they're equal to one
another neither of these are hypotonic
or hypertonic any more once an
equilibrium and a balance has been
established this is what a isotonic
solution is and so if you've seen the
word hypo tonic hypertonic and isotonic
in cooperation with one or a combination
with one another I hope
explains what those are so as we wrap up
this video if you're you know in my
biology class pause the video and try to
answer these questions on a separate
sheet of paper and I hope you found this
helpful thanks for watching